earlier today uh outside on edgar
martinez drive they had the unveiling of
the new edgar martinez statue tyler
anderson 31 year old left-hander who
will start for the third time for
seattle he has pitched twice on the road
this will be his first home start and
here is center fielder adolesce garcia
now look out for garcia one for five
last night jumped on a first pitch
fastball and wrote it out
in the top half of the ninth inning the
wind up and the 2-2 pitch fastball swing
out of his strike three he follows up
the off-speed pitch with a fastball
strikes out garcia his first of the
night and it's a one two three top of
the first inning for the texas rangers
we go to the bottom of the first going
for the rangers tonight spencer howard
came over from the phillies and the kyle
gibson ian kennedy trade throws a bit of
everything working off a 95 mile an hour
fastball here's jp crawford there's a
swing and a bouncing ball on the right
side sliding to grab it as a banyas
throws from the outfield grass bounces
the throw and low picks it
kyle seeger is coming up next
two balls two strikes
and the pitch
breaking ball struck him out swinging
beautiful slow curve ball there at 74
miles an hour
as seeger whiffs for the second out of
the inning
and that will bring up ty france the
cleanup batter who went three for five
yesterday
he's hitting 280 with 11 homers and 49
runs batted in he had an rbi single in
the bottom of the 10th inning driving in
the zombie runner but the rangers had
scored two in the top of the inning and
that would be the last run the mariners
would score in the rangers 5-4 victory a
look at second here's the pitch swung on
and line to right field toward the alley
diving for the ball
and making the catches dj peters wow
what a play
as peters with a backhand diving catch
robs france of a hit and a run batted in
and puts an end to the first inning
tremendous play by peters
no runs a hit one left after one no
score so we'll see what dj peters can do
here about breaking the scoreless tie
hitting 192 as a ranger five for 26 no
homer's a run bad at him it's exactly
what he hit with the dodgers this year
in his limited playing time
want to know and here's the pitch and
there's a high drive to deep center
field helnick going back he's still
going and on the track he makes the
catch bumps up against the wall tagging
and scoring his nathaniel lowe it's a
long sacrifice fly for dj peters he
gives the rangers a one to nothing lead
one nothing rangers top of any number
two here is designated hitter curtis
terry
runners get their leads
now the set and the anderson 0-2 pitch
again fastball strike three called he
got him looking and that will retire the
side strikeout number two for anderson
but the rangers get a run here in the
second we go to the bottom of any number
two now cal raleigh the switch hitting
catcher
hitting 175 a homer 10 rbis
the 2-2 pitch swing in a miss and down
goes raleigh he chased a high pitch
as that one came in around shoulder high
at 92
second strikeout for howard is the
dangerous center fielder adolesce garcia
one nothing rangers top of the third
here t-mobile park a one-two to garcia
right-hand hitter from the lefty
anderson swaying in a mess and a
changeup came up empty two down
bowers spanning 214 on the year three
homers and
14 runs driven in
now pitch and he strikes out bowers
third strikeout tonight
for spitzer howard france
hit a line drive into right center his
first time up peters made a diving catch
hearn's o2 pitch hit on the ground deep
in the hole with short backhanded by
connor falefa he goes to second for one
on to first a double play good turn
there by andy abanyas but an even better
start by connor falefa who came in and
to his right and backhanded that as he
was sliding down to his left knee but he
popped up quickly
and made a good feed over to abanya so a
six four three double play wipes out the
walk to see her
kalnika 149 hit her overall
his first stint with the mariners just
was having an awful time he's been
better here in his second stint
raising his season's average up to 149
the one strike pitch
that's it high into the air pretty deep
into left center but garcia to his right
has it measured and makes the catch to
retire kelnick for the final out no runs
a hit and one left we'll move along now
to the fifth inning from seattle where
the rangers lead in one to nothing
that'll bring up does he need to hit her
curtis terry big kid and he fills up the
right side of the batter's box
all for one as anderson struck him out
in the second inning tyler has three
strikeouts on the day
now he saws him off but this is a
troubling ground ball seeger
gets it there in time
terry not the most fleet of foot but
nevertheless seeger
getting that throw to first base in the
nick of time for round number two two
outs here in the fifth rangers leading
one nothing yanni hernandez coming up
anderson with the new baseball looks in
the sign the set kinder philippe related
second two outs the one-two to hernandez
swinging a fly ball into shallow left
center field racing in fraley on the run
and he makes the catch and that will
retire the side nice running catch by
jake to end the inning we're at the
halfway point we go to the bottom of the
fifth our home street banks score the
rangers one and the merits nothing
brings up nathaniel lowe the first
baseman
double run scored in the second inning
and the ground out the second in the
third one for two
swinging a miss struck him out in a
slider and a good one needed it too
now you got to get jonah heim who has
been a thorn in the side
of the mariners
the race is on joe smith county joe
smith he makes the catch
way to go joe smith
everybody smiling around smitty giving a
pound to
cal raleigh and kyle seeger hey kyle was
in the shift so smitty was the only one
that could get it and he's gassed after
that long run that'll do it for the
rangers in the sixth they strand the
runner we go bottom six and the batter
will be mitch haniger
a long hold by hearn and the pitch and
that's popped into short left center
field a long run out for connor follefa
he slides and makes an incredible catch
what a play by connor falefa
back to the infield sliding to make a
basket catch and rob mitch haniger of a
base hit what a play by izzy
an opportunity now for jared kelnick
turned to the plate the pits inside
almost hitting walkthrough tie score 1-1
rbi for kelnick is 17.
and here is raleigh who has struck you
out and walked switch hitter will bat
right against taylor hearn
and here comes the pitch
strike three call at the knees
hearn gets a borderline call and the
inning is over
but the mariners tie it up a run on a
hit they leave them loaded and we've
completed six rangers one mariners one
chance tonight for the mariners ninth
walk-off win
and the batter is luis terence who pitch
it for jake bowers in the bottom of the
seventh inning and now terence with an
opportunity to win it lorenz a chance to
win it
into center field and the
[Applause]
luis
mariners
walk off revenge against texas
and the mariners win it two to one a
walk-off single by louise terence who is
getting mobbed up there at second base
for the mariners their ninth walk-off
win of the 20-21 season the mariners
were looking for a healthy fly ball and
terrence had health and more
off the wall in center field to win it
as jared kellnick scores from third base
and the mariners take game two of this
three-game series a final score of two
to one and terenza's just surrounded by
his teammates out there near second base